I honestly feel very very happy to be a
part of this project that's singer
Shakira clearly excited about her new
role at disney zootopia playing gazelle
who's also a pop star she's fun and
she's charismatic but she's also very
aware and socially aware she feels
responsible for her people and she
stands up for them when they need her
the entertainer is also featured on the
film soundtracks singing try everything
try everything is a song about being
unafraid of your own dreams and the
sides of your under of your own dreams
and and being able to fight for them and
follow them
the 38 year old is now a mother to two
young boys but adorably admitted she was
a Disney fan log before more than once I
found myself by myself on a couch
watching these new movies with a big jar
of popcorn but I also think that is very
cool now to brag to my son about my
connection to Mickey Mouse for more from
Shakira and gizelle tune in to ET
wednesday and check out Zootopia in
theaters march forth